check out this story from Yahoo finance
from I should say from Fortune Elon Musk
insists he's restricting Ukraine's
access to starlinked because starlink
because zelenski could start World War
III this is I I heard him I mean he's
been talking about this
Elon Musk has a message for whoever
might blame him for a Third World War I
took over Ukraine it's not his fault in
fact his decision to restrict Ukrainian
access to his communication technology
he's disabling satellite Broadband use
for any potential strikes on Russian
soil could help prevent the conflict
from spiraling out of control if you ask
him that is it's kind of crazy to think
right that they need access to a private
infrastructure to engage in conflict and
one man just said no that's the whole
reason that's like one of the best
Arguments for libertarianism that I've
ever heard one dude is just like no you
can't use my toys to start a war and I
know there are people that are going to
have a feeling about Elon Musk and have
an opinion on it but I mean it's it's
the opposite of that well I mean yeah
there could be a guy that could align
against the country that he lives in
absolutely but in this context it is a
positive or a billionaire who runs a
weapons contractor who's like yes I will
build for you weapons to strike that
country that currently happens right so
I mean there that currently happens and
they're in bed with the government and
so they they use those weapons with
impunity they don't have any kind of
there's there's not really a whole lot
of of uh backlash from from the
International Community against uh
anyone that anyone that the U.S allows
to either anyone that the US sells
weapons to or the anyone that the US
decides to make a strike on their behalf
the strikes in Yemen the U.S supporting
the the uh conflict in Yemen and stuff
like there's it would be really cool if
someone had Boeing was like yo stop
killing the people in Yemen with our
missiles I think that it's a net
positive that Elon Musk not only isn't
making weapons but he's saying hey I'm
not going to help to do you know help
you start a war I'm kind of worried
about Elon Musk I got to tell you why
you know everything he's doing certainly
is pissing people off
very powerful angry people yeah you know
starlink neurolink you know I mean he's
pissing everybody off there's another
thing the uh the Biden Administration is
going after him over knurling yeah there
was something today that I saw yeah I
don't remember he's a new bad guy you
know yeah I think uh Matt tabe was
saying that on uh Joe Rogan just the
other day when I saw him I forget what
website that was but oh is this it
they're saying it's uh under
investigation for unsafe transport of
contaminated Hardware yeah yeah but it's
it's it's just the by the administration
going after the you know Elon Musk for
being the you know The Whipping Boy or
De Jour he's a new bag guy
generally agree with you but there is
stuff about Elon Musk that just gives me
slight pause right we talk about like
how is Tesla able to operate in in China
the way it is like there are moments
that I want to believe that Elon Musk is
like on the ball but there there are
some questions and I don't tend to trust
the Biden Administration so on this side
I would side with Elon Musk on the other
hand I'm a full-on technophobe maybe it
is contaminated contemporated with what
I'm not a technophobe and I also am not
the dude that really
is I'm not usually a cheerleader for
people
um I do like the stuff that Elon Musk
does I like his stance on having big
families yeah huge fan yeah and I like
the fact that he said you know he's when
he made a remark about you know what if
there's an oppressive government that
says you can't have this uh this the
internet access over this area and he
was just like you can shake your fist to
the sky I I dig that kind of stuff
um but there's every like it's
completely possible that he's as
corrupted as as any other you know large
company owner he does operate in China
now if you expect someone to be 100 pure
all the time I think you're always going
to be let down
um so I do think that musk is still
better than most
um but again I don't know the guys I
think there's a few things that I've
always I always like to see you know
he's got some good stuff on Twitter I
think that he in terms of Shifting the
the the cultural conversation I think he
says a lot of things that get a lot of
people on the right side and I want to I
want to agree with him but then there's
the things that give me the pause like
wanting to put chips in people's brains
and he wore that weird Antichrist
demonic armored one time to a Hollywood
party and I don't know about you guys
but that kind of affects me I notice
things like that like you're decked out
like a demon
as an isolated incident maybe but I
don't know I also think that maybe
you're in neuralink right now and you
don't know you might have never liked me
Elon Musk like goes into your house and
he plugs the New Orleans you like wake
up and he's grabbing you and he's like
holding himself that's why that's why
Kennedy said lock your doors because
Elon Musk will come and put a chip oh
it's all and then once together so what
happens is he plugs it into your brain
your eyes turn white and you get up and
say
yes Elon tell me your command and then
in your mind like life is going on like
normal and you're just doing your job
and you have no idea that he's taken
control and you've become the actual the
new Tesla AI that they're trying it's
like Black Mirror that's like some Black
Mirror stuff you know what I don't want
to move away from Ohio everything is
safe here everything is fine
yeah man I don't know I I think that the
China stuff is what what gives me pause
the neuraling stuff is actually kind of
creepy but you know a lot of people have
mentioned that it's it's it's
potentially going to cure people who
have been paralyzed or or other it can I
think it can treat like epilepsy and
stuff like that or Parkinson's so I mean
maybe and if there's new technology you
want to believe it's for the best right
but I don't trust AI I don't understand
why we make that a fun toy to hang out
with I mean we just don't know what
these things are going to do and
unfortunately that uh applies to their
creators the reality is you have no idea
how bad it will be yeah when Twitter
comes out I remember in the early days
of Twitter me and a bunch of young
people are like tweeting things and
posting pictures like wow it's giving a
voice the voiceless look what we can do
it's revolutionizing news now it's a
nightmare dystopian hellscape of people
screaming at the top of their lungs the
the way I would analogize Twitter would
be akin to walking into a daycare center
where every kid at the same time is is
going
that's Twitter that's because you have
like a million and a half followers no
that's sweater it doesn't matter I have
like 100 and it is the same thing for me
yeah exactly the same thing so I just I
just don't I I don't even look at
mentions I just completely it's been
that way for a long time yeah it's just
screaming so bad it's so bad for your
mental health you're talking about
mental health again yeah it's so but
it's also indicative of the mental
health of others right which is again
terrifying I don't want to know how
other people are doing I mean I say
daycare imagine yeah imagine imagine
walking into a stadium with every person
just screaming face beat red that's
Twitter and we thought it was going to
be good so Elon I think he needs to
understand this he's gonna he's gonna
come on be like with no link we can cure
parallels this and and make everyone's
lives better and I really think it's
gonna be a great thing and then
literally it's going to be in 10 years
everyone's doing zombie marches with
their brains controlled by chat GPT
I mean we've we've talked about you know
the dangers of of being able to you know
use neuralink to
give people little hits of dopamine
every time they read something that you
know whoever controls the the neuralink
wants them to think you it's completely
plausible that a chip in your brain
could brainwash you if it can control
any of your motor functions or anything
you know I think
I think it's possible
the fir one of the first implementations
of neuralink
for for people in this context will be
uh convicted criminals
will be given the option
you can go to jail
or I get the neuraling the neural link
will inhibit your ability to commit
crimes
that's that's dangerous yeah that's
that's like people didn't like it in
Massachusetts like you could donate
organs to leave prison early I mean I
don't know and they're gonna say this
you have a three-year jail sentence we
can lock you up but it's cheaper to just
install neuralink
which will inhibit your ability to
commit crimes you you will have to wear
it for three years and then the state
can remove it and if you break it damage
it like an ankle bracelet or monitor
then yeah you know it's it alerts them
and then you're wanted and they come
after you but I mean honest question
what would you pick it sensor this is
getting close to the Demolition Man kind
of stuff yeah but in Demolition Man they
like cryogenically freeze you or
whatever would you rather be locked up
for three years or be given the
neurolink implant for three years lock
me up lock me up for 10 honestly yeah
something gets you get mad during
traffic and it senses that your you know
your hormones start to bump because
someone cut you off you flick them off
and all of a sudden neural Link's gonna
seize you up while you're on the highway
it would neural link would would not
make you would not be able to get mad
you'd be driving you and where you
normally would get mad you'd be like you
know what I'm just not mad that he cut
me off I don't know what if someone
breaks into your house it's your
adrenaline spikes but the neurolic
misinterprets that as to you taking
risky Behavior right you guys are
thinking of norlink and too much in a
rudimentary confession what if I have it
for three years but two and a half years
in they pass the laws saying well
actually if you do this program you need
to uh have it for him for six years well
law is typically grandfather in that
regard so it's like any what if they
don't I don't want to gamble I mean
that's I I feel like I would rather go
to jail than to gamble with putting in
someone else's technology in too much
I couldn't do that and I'm saying I
believe this will be the implementation
and 90 nine percent of people are going
to be like yeah I'd much rather not go
to jail so give me the door link they
probably would like people get ankle
bracelets dude the government tracks
your location yeah people are willing to
accept that level of surveillance and
control there that I'll leave it at that
without getting into the more darker
subjects of what the government has
offered people in terms of alternative
treatment yeah we want to hear about it
maybe after the show yeah chemical
castration oh yeah giving people pills
and saying here's your option this and
they say Okay so
neurolink is not going to be so
rudimentary that it's like warning you
are becoming angry we will Now notify
the place no norlink won't let you be
angry yeah exactly it will it will be
tracking all data in and out of your
brain I don't know how long it'll take
for me to get to this point but I
imagine not that far away and it will it
will actively block you from getting mad
you like like
someone will cut you off and and while
you're driving on the highway and you'll
be like no you know I hope he's having a
good day
monitoring court or regulating cortisol
reaction and stuff like that is is just
as simple if they can if they can Bridge
a a break in your spinal column if they
can figure out a way to do that then
they can absolutely uh manipulate your
adrenal gland your cortisone response
your all that kind of stuff what if you
have it in and someone murders your
spouse and so you have an immediate
cortisol anger response but then it
doesn't let you so you can't feel angry
that someone has damaged some like kill
someone you love I just I just can't go
down this path and if it's better for
you I mean I want to believe in Freedom
and you know autonomy with your own body
but especially if it's issued by the
government like I I this is the thing
about 10 years in prison 15. this is the
thing about AI in general
your Tesla auto drive is driving down
the street
when all of a sudden two people jump out
from each lane
it's a woman and a man
the Tesla is going to hit both of them
unless it swerves left or right
which way does it swerve would you
choose to kill
I have no idea how they how they decided
that this is one of the biggest problems
with AI if the if the self-driving car
is about to hit an old lady it can
swerve out of the way but crash into a
wall killing the driver
who's safe you should have prioritized I
think I know it would depend on who has
the higher Social score so yeah yeah oh
man dude
can communicate with the car and let
them know what your score is at all
times and who is setting the rubric for
score like did you see the stuff about
the Yale Professor who's like Unilever
yeah that would be great no I'm talking
about the yield Professor who uh
Experian said that he he should
encourage suicide among um yeah elderly
populations uh you're gonna you're gonna
be you're gonna have Experian uh Equifax
and was it TransUnion yeah and they're
going to give you your social credit
score and then it's gonna you're a bad
person so we're gonna choose to save the
good person the car is going to know who
to hit thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time